all right got a new stand-up hour
september 28th we're in madison
wisconsin september 29th we're in
milwaukee wisconsin september 30th
chicago theater is sold out october 1st
the fillmore in minneapolis there's like
five tickets left wisconsin get the tiki
wikis to 28th and 29th uk and ireland
london
second show at bloomsbury theater almost
sold out ireland dublin hall we are
adding a show tickets are on sale
tomorrow or today check the website they
might i'm sorry they're on sale right
now
uh liberty hall in dublin second show
added 10 p.m october 10th and then the
next night in belfast october 11th at
limelight all my other dates are up
there christy comedy.com but wisconsin
get your tickets uk and ireland get your
tickets thank you
i love you and i want to see you and if
you're watching this i hope that you
love me too
i tour the world doing stand-up comedy
and if you've seen me you've had a good
time i know that and if you haven't seen
me come see me and have a good time all
my tour dates are up right now and i
start touring very soon again october
14th and 15th for the first time ever
i'm up at canada i've been asked to come
to canada for like seven years and i
have not been there i'm playing hamilton
and toronto toronto has actually showed
up so much that we added a second show
richmond virginia and hershey
pennsylvania october 28th and 29th
hershey pennsylvania we were sold out
and we had to add a second show richmond
virginia i've never been there gato was
just there he had a great time he told
me he was going to plug my shows in
richmond while he was on stage i don't
know if he did if you saw him write to
me and let me know if he lied to me but
i will excited about richmond now we're
moving on to november and november i
have a banging weekend on the 11th 12th
and 13th i am in knoxville can't wait to
come to knoxville i did nashville and i
did um
uh what's the other place in tennessee
that i did not memphis
uh knoxville tennessee you guys always
come out hard i'm so excited to go to
knoxville um atlanta my first time solo
in atlanta i'm so excited we added a
second show in atlanta atlanta and
phoenix are the two places that i get
requested the most atlanta i heard you
i'm coming we added a show at the center
stage theater on november 12th november
13th i'm in birmingham alabama also our
first time i love birmingham my boy roy
wood jr reps birmingham and i can't wait
to come down there at the alabama
theater november 18th and 19th
these are shows that were postponed from
the pandemic and i cannot wait to get to
louisville and i keep being told i'm
pronouncing that wrong louisville
louisville louisville
um i'm so excited to go to louisville uh
on uh the 18th of november at the brown
theater and then the evans uh in
evansville indiana home of don mattingly
victory theater on november 19th
and i round off december in florida and
california and i hope you come
december big weekend in florida december
2nd 3rd and 4th
at jacksonville jacksonville never been
there excited i'm playing the florida
theater if you know someone in
jacksonville florida let them know tampa
we're adding a second show
december 3rd at the tampa theater tampa
comes out huge eric a second show there
thank you and then orlando florida hard
rock live in orlando is gonna be a
banger orlando's fun the hard rock's fun
i'm fun that's a triple whammy december
16th this is my last tour dates of the
year in uh
northern california sacramento
uh on december 16th at the crest theater
[Music]
[Music]
now let me ask you now here's the thing
with this show one thing i pride about
this show one thing a lot of the fans
have talked about on the show is how
genuine the conversations are how
nothing is forced and everything is
organic wow now with that being said i
heard your father has a neck tattoo
it's funny you should ask chris yes
my dad yeah dude my dad i just thought
my dad i didn't know it didn't tell me
it didn't tell me it's wild to think
what i like but you know what it's it's
actually
really really cool because you would
think most men over 70 right your dad is
yeah my dad is in the second half of 70s
so most men over 70 i would argue most
men over 40 would say um my time to get
a neck tattoo is passed yes and i'll
never do it it takes a certain kind of
confidence in a man to say
i don't care now's the time i'm only
going to go around this planet once i've
always wanted a neck tattoo i'm going to
get it and he got it i i i didn't know
that he he didn't always want a neck
tattoo did he ever express any interest
at all he had a few tattoos he got
started getting tattoos like like when
he's like 50 actually right and he got
one here one here one here that was
pretty much the extent of it and then i
go to his house like a few weeks ago
and i see a tattoo on his neck we didn't
even run it by the kids no
like you may have called him one day or
texted him and he didn't respond to the
guys in the shower he's working but he
was getting a neck tattoo he got a neck
tattoo and i was like what is that he
goes oh yeah i i
i got i got a tattoo i was like on your
neck yeah and he said yeah and i said
i was speechless and i said you didn't
even tell me because he got initials of
his kids like you know
okay
well that i mean that what place were
you in
on the next in the way of age oh okay so
he just did it he just did it the way
god gave it to him he didn't pick
favorites
and uh unless he likes us in the order
we were born you know i'll never know so
wait are you the oldest i'm second
oldest okay yeah okay but um and then
and then i looked down huge tattoo on
his forearm
same tattoos that weren't there three
weeks ago no so did he do the neck and
the form in the same day couldn't do it
in the same sesh i i think he did well
hold on because then we went in the pool
he took over shirt huge tattoo on his
chest
i said when did you get all these
tattoos i i just went i wanted to do it
did he run it by any of your other
siblings that you know apparently my
niece who's like a tattoo connoisseur or
whatever she has like her whole body
covered or whatever okay she took him to
her person
and so she's the only one that knew
about this she's the only one i think
that knew and is it just one of those
things where he just doesn't want to
make it a big deal like what do you
think his
reason was for not telling anybody i i
don't know would you have talked him out
of it
i think he knew he knows i would have
tried you'd have been like dad that's
not the move yeah i think you know i
mean god bless it it's a nice thing to
do and he's got it now but i don't think
i was thinking about this because i
don't think i guess
it's not running through his head i want
a tattoo let me clear with anybody else
imagine you were like he was like um you
were like what is really the reason you
what is the inspiration for that tattoo
and he went machine gun kelly
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
speaking of tattoos i went out to dinner
yesterday with my friends from home one
of my friends has a tattoo on his form
that says cadillac
oh jesus oh my god
that is definitely he goes he goes yo he
goes from new york he goes can i get um
he puts his arm out you know he had a
long security puts armor to the waiter
he goes he goes yo can we get some apps
and i said what does that say on your
arm he's like oh kia sportage yeah
i go what does that say he goes cadillac
i was like why do you have the word
cadillac tattooed he goes because
because cadillac's the best american car
that's ever been made and i'm the best
american body that's ever been made i
was like you have gout
you gotta look under that hood buddy you
gotta look on the hood dude you have he
was complaining about his gout all night
while he put him oh there was that he's
got the word cadillac
you got a flat tire on that cat got the
best american body
you ever go back and hang out with your
friends from home and i know people with
cadillac tattoo by the way oh so is this
a common thing that's kind of like the
only reason i know this is because my
dad like he got a vintage cadillac okay
right um it's like 30 year old it's like
a
classic car now it's closer and so he he
goes to car shows okay and especially
cadillac shows okay
and when he goes he has this group of
friends this community of cadillac
enthusiasts okay and they go all the way
back to like the 50s right it's really
cool i went to it one time they all like
they all descend on like a parking lot
the hoods are up yeah music this food
it's kind of cool yeah but um
so
i think i think it's like this
the cadillac club it's called i forgot
exactly what it's called but anyway uh
there's guys in there that have cadillac
tattoos yeah i i get look
if you're a lover of cars like i guess
but like it is hysterical
because it's like
and just cattle just the word cadillac
just right there but cadillac seems like
one of the only ones i could be like i
know
the guy
and why he would get it and i could see
it what's another car
that you think someone would get a
tattoo of yeah like
i mean you can't get bmw to or
mercedes-benz like
i bet you i could see a a guido getting
like mercedes-benz written out you know
what i bet you somebody has i bet you a
guy out there has either huge on his
back or over his belly but the
mercedes-benz symbol yes that symbol
looks kind of cool that's the only other
one what else though yeah you can't
that's it there's really no you think
about it there's really no other yeah
i'm not gonna get jetta tattooed
like a subaru yeah right yeah yeah i
don't think um by the way uh i might get
the word volkswagen tattooed on my arm
you guys great deals out right now on
the volkswagen atlas check it out
the contract is not over there yeah
obligations no i was told to i had to
make three public statements somewhere
on unboxing
about volkswagen i get a bonus check
then i'll cross split with you
um uh no i think that yeah i think yeah
cadillac
i'm i'm gonna say i'm gonna say and i'm
gonna say this i'm gonna take a stance i
i think you get any card name tattooed
on your body it's it's a wild choice for
me it's wild it's a wild choice but but
but if you must cadillac
for an american seems like the one
that makes the most sense to get isn't
ford the most american with ford a lot
of people say that it's like a [ __ ]
product now cadillac is supposedly like
the creme de la creme a legend
allegedly
award like this i could picture someone
having like a ford tough yeah
yeah meanwhile i just purchased the
lincoln navigator which is a ford car oh
really yeah
lincoln yeah it's all the same thing oh
i can't keep up with these merch i can't
give it up either it would be funny it
would be funny
like to get like um you have to get one
what is it
i have to you have to i have to get a
name of a car on my arm yeah
i go funny right i mean i love i i tend
to like the bmw as a car but i'm not a
car guy yeah it's just you know that's
the car i kind of like that i draw like
you know but i think if i had to get one
it's got to be something it would be
funny like i would get like in my i
would like on my home nissan pathfinder
[Laughter]
maybe like a ford fiesta yeah fourth
year actually this is good it's fun you
know or maybe you could just get away
with it and say fiesta i need you know
because it's not technically a car name
but a fiesta right i would get saturn
old school cars oh sat neon oh dodgy
remember dodge neon of course you
you don't see saturn went out of
business you know what saturn's thing
was my grandfather was used to get sound
and she always used to lease them
because unlimited warranty or something
that and what their pitch was is an
effort to get more women into the
dealership to not get taken advantage of
by like sleazy car salesmen there was no
negotiation of a price with the saturn
you bought it for the msrp sticker
that's what it is you cannot negotiate
it the it doesn't go up or down this is
what it is you buy it like that no that
was saturn's thing there is no how is
that a deal how is that enticing because
women would sometimes
be
or more guys who didn't know much about
cars oh am i going to get
is that going to be intimidated there's
no role oh yeah you know like this car
it's 80 grand but really it's 68 but
they're going to tell you it's 80. it's
the top of the line and you're paying
over where saturn the company made a
statement saying our cars are this price
okay you can't negot our salesman how
how arizona iced tea puts 99 cents on 99
cents okay but that that sounds in
theory like good but all that means is
that they're just holding firm on their
msi yeah yeah they they said yeah it's
not like that's what they pay yeah they
said instead of saturn made a decision
said instead of screwing
five out of ten we're gonna screw ten
energy we're gonna screw everyone that
walks to us
right out of business like it's like
listen
don't be scared to come in here we'll
guarantee you if you come in you just
pay full price yeah just full price yeah
yeah it's so i think i think yeah that's
an interesting question about what what
car would you get on pimp uh the
delorean
nice
that's probably the winner you took a
yeah that's that's the smartest you had
the most time to think though so it
doesn't count yeah i mean i would get on
that i would get night rot kit on me too
you know yeah
um do you know kit
knight rider
you do know knight rider the guy with
the mullet would talk to his car david
hasselhoff
michael knight
how do you know it uh i used to get yeah
high when i dropped out of school and
watch
dukes are hazardous knight rider yeah
that's it yeah
yeah
no i mean that's that's pretty that's
great i remember i remember one time i
was watching when my parents got
divorced my dad would come over a lot
when i was young like six seven and on
saturday mornings we'd go play baseball
something like that but i remember this
one morning it was raining and we were
watching night rider a lot when i was a
kid it was like always on channel five
on like saturday afternoons i guess it
was reruns at that time
is that andre dawson who is that pedro
martinez
oh it's pedro martinez yeah pedro
martinez rookie uh jersey number 45 on
the back okay
it was a trump joke
so we're sitting there watching knight
rider which you know i loved and then my
mom and dad you know divorce were you
know
squabbling over something and my mom had
um uh was dating a guy at the time not
gary the mall santa yet some other guy
um who's i actually liked him
and he um and all of a sudden kyle the
easter bunny yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so so she um
so so they start arguing about something
i don't remember but i just remember my
dad out of nowhere being like because my
mom was like oh what are you watching
this show for he's two young friends and
he was like he was like what what are
you gonna date david hasselhoff too
and i remember thinking like there's no
way david household would go after my
mom
like we live in like this [ __ ] box
apartment you know like it's not you
know yeah no my mom was was is hot it
was hot back in the day what do you guys
think is the worst sitcom ever made or
the worst show
ever made
the worst sitcom ever made yeah
there was a show called dad's that was
on nbc that i saw very briefly that was
so painfully unfunny was that with matt
leblanc by any chance i think it might
have been with anthony anderson okay
google dad's anthony anderson or or
dad's yeah maybe it was an nbc maybe
been a jimmy kimmel show
nbc dads yep dad
jimmy kimmel this american sitcom this
was
something from 30 years truthfully the
the the the couple of
moments i see how many episodes it got
right there yeah 19 after one season
yeah because it was um
it was it was so painfully bad from what
i remember oh alex this could be the
wrong show though that's the guy from uh
family guy this could be the wrong show
actually maybe dads wasn't google i'm
sure that name's been used yeah it's not
that because anything with seth
macfarlane actually can't be bad he's
too funny for things to be bad so it
wasn't this show then i remember
google dad's jimmy fallon
i thought jimmy found because even jimmy
fallon made a joke about it on his show
like
you know not as bad as my sitcom or
something it could the show might not be
called dad's name you guys remember when
they gave the geico cavemen there on
sitcom yes you know who that was no nick
kroll
nick kroll was the guy
man and somebody else two two two wait a
minute nick kroll this whole time has
been the guy
man yes i like
that's
one of the most mind-blowing things he
must have made a lot of money
i don't know if he was the caveman in
the commercials
what cavemen it was called
yeah nick kroll bill english nick crowe
wow i wonder what that if we watch that
right now what it would
there was also another horrific show on
abc where that where um the the star of
the show was a dog
then there was another show on fox where
the co-lead of the show was a cartoon
everything else what they all these
these they got canceled immediately yeah
enjoying your modern civilization
you might want to send us a little thank
you now
that sounds like nick crawl right
we're right here beside you we're really
not that different from you just a
little better look at it what a bad idea
yeah
i love nature well those commercials
were
the biggest pop culture foundation like
right now if you if you pitched me to
say hey should we give flo from
progressive a sitcom and i was an
executive i would say yeah i think so
why not right
see i can't even tell which one nick
kroll is can you tell who nick is in
that makeup no by the way nick kroll i
know a lot of our fans know him but nick
kroll i think not that he's even
underrated but he might be like one of
the funniest comedians ever like do you
ever want like you've ever seen oh i
know we talk about key and peel a lot
here but the kroll show i've seen
crosstalk was what so
it was amazing like lizzy publicity
right the referee character that he does
i know blizz publicity won the ref guy
the the the bobby bottle service bobby
boss like
because he was never on snl you know
nick crawl was never on snl
i mean he
he is the perfect snl yeah i used to see
him a lot at ucb he's fantastic i used
to i started out like in like
the year 2000 like over there so i used
to go see like a lot of the sketch shows
over there and bobby bottle service was
all a character he did ucb and he did um
he did another guy i forget his name but
he was a he was the kate he was in
charge of crass services for the raven
simone show that was the character yeah
nick kroll's character yeah yeah that's
a funny
funny
can you put nick
raven simone that's right like a nick
like to see nick kroll and tim robertson
team up on something would be wild and
oh god their brains together would be
wild uh just it was like fabrice fabrice
yeah nick grove fabrice
yeah i love nick crawl and that and i
guess fabrice fabrice was uh the the
caterer
the caterer for
that so ifc used to be like such a big
channel for comedy and kind of is not a
thing anymore right or is it still i
don't know if it's a network at all i
don't know
um wait a second so so before we go into
nick kroll your father got the neck
tattoo yeah and the other and then your
mother yeah my mom
your parents are your parents are your
parents feel like podcast guests
i guarantee you'll be good would that
actually be that might actually be i'm
talking about at the same time your mom
and dad and my mom and dad all on the
couch at the same time we just bring in
eight mics and we do like we do like
just uh
they're going at it god that's crazy we
let them do an episode of hay babe
together as if they were us and see what
they could come up with
that'd be funny if we got just like our
mom or dad here gave him the mic and
then
stood over there turn the mics on and be
like talk for an hour now
and see what comes out just get them
getting know each other it'll also be
funny to send you guys out to lunch so
you're
and full watch we watch about the
episode and it's pretty much just both
our moms coming to inclusion both their
sons are gay
they're like allegedly
yeah well they just talk about like they
actually do like the fans are like
they [ __ ] crush our moms
yeah
or we put an earpiece in and you guys do
the pot through them oh yeah oh my god
start talking about all that yeah mom
you like sal's mom says yo [ __ ] on dad's
neck tattoos i tell my mom like ask ask
like what the ask the things the worst
things you think about my dad
that's i mean i would pay for that one
so your mom wants for the patreon so
your mom asked that she won a mountain
bike skull
my mom told me recently that
for her birthday she really would love a
mountain bike
okay so let me what's your birthday by
the way uh it's well it's in april but
she was talking about it like because in
april i i think i like took it whatever
i did but i i was like
she's a um no
no yes aries
right april 4th makes sense yeah aries
yeah it doesn't no they love mountain
bikes they're known to love nine bucks
no she goes she no it was like it was
like i'll let you know when i i was like
what do you want and she was like i'll
let you know when i think of something i
don't want to just get anything for
anything sick so it was april that was
back in april so like like two months
ago like maybe july she goes oh i know
what i want and she goes
if you if you don't mind i'd love a
mountain bike and i was like where
for context i have never in my entire
life seen my mom on a bicycle
not one time not a single single time in
my entire life i see my dad on one yeah
he used to put me on the chair in the
back and it's fun never your mother not
once ever my mom now she's even like a
like a woman who's into the gym or no
yeah and and and and she's in her 70s as
well and i'm like where are you gonna
ride a mountain bike and she goes around
my neighborhood
and i go ma
yeah i go i i appreciate it i do i don't
want to take that from you i go but like
you've never ridden a bike in your life
like you're going to get on a bike alone
yeah and then go up and down the streets
of your neighborhood on a mountain bike
in your 70s yeah and she's like yes
and i was like god forbid yeah like you
would pull a biden yeah didn't biden
fall off a bike i fell right off the
bike i go gotham you fall or whatever
and she's like i'm not gonna fall
whatever yeah but she very well could
fall a hundred percent so i let it but
you're gonna get it for her i let it go
and then the other day she texted me the
bike
out of nowhere yeah she's like this is
the bike i want
and you know it's not it's on amazon
it's only 200 bucks which i think sounds
cheap for a bike
yeah maybe you should do research and
just get her
like
the safest bike out there on the market
yeah but i still am nervous about it
what do you think about that
um yeah i think that i think that i
would be uneasy here's here's what i'm
gonna get on a bicycle that did not have
been on in a long time yeah it's not
like i mean you get it right back away
but even i have felt unsteady on a bike
100 yeah i i personally would be like i
think it would funny i think it would be
cool
i would
i would be very very nervous with her on
it i would i would say this i will buy
you i will buy you a bicycle but you
also have to
have a life alert you have to have a
life alert
or some type of way well that's sobering
to be like mom you can get on a bicycle
but you need to have an alarm attached
to you i'm attached to you yeah or let
me or text me every single time you
leave the house with that bike i know
like you have to you gotta wear a helmet
well no it gets to a point my mom is
gonna wear a helmet 100 just away how
much you should wear elbow pads knee
pads because it gets to the point now
where we're at the time now where our
parents are becoming like it's reverse
now it's our responsibility to guide
like they're become our children now
eventually uh yeah it's going that way
where it's like now you got to listen to
me you're not being safe yeah out there
in a goddamn bicycle that's why actually
you got to have kids
because they have to take care of you
later yeah and if you don't who's taking
care of you the state that's crazy shh
not after what cuomo did
[Laughter]
hello
hello hey i'm hey hey hello fresh hey
how are you
i'm doing well i wanted to ask you yes
do you cost more money than the
supermarket no
you don't no
do you have fit
so much cheaper can you make meals for
me 20 minutes yeah
20 minutes 30 minutes whatever you like
hey hello fresh yes hello
are you here to make my hectic fall week
nights a little easier and more
delicious delicious yes i know you're
going to say that i have quick and easy
meals including my 20 minute meals my
low prep meals my easy clean up options
and i want to take the stress out of
your meal time with my time saving no
fuss recipes um that already in a snap
honestly hello fresh hi how are you is
fall the perfect time to cozy up with
some delicious sweets yes it is yes
hi
can i get the whole family involved with
your limited edition kid-friendly baking
kits can i yeah absolutely wow
hello fresh isn't just for dinners you
know
shop me
hello fresh market for quick breakfast
some of my wholesome snacks and even
desserts hello fresh hi
how do how
let me ask you a question
are you into giving fans of the hey bay
podcast discounts if they order through
you it's why i came here today really
yes to speak to you and to the fans
because honestly if you guys go to
hellofresh.com16 and use hey babe the
code heybabe16 you'll get 16 free meals
across the seven boxes i sent you and
plus on top of that because i'm in a
good mood i'm also gonna send you three
free gifts wow
just go to hellofresh.com that's my
website slash hey babe one six and use
the code hey babe one six yes that's a
reference to your podcast for 16 free
meals is what i'm giving you and you
heard that right 16 16. free meals and
across seven boxes but then i'm also in
such a good mood i'm gonna give you guys
three free gifts three literally this
offer is so great by hellofresh giving
them going to hellofresh.com putting in
that code hey babe one six aka hey babe
16 that they're actually it's causing an
uproar because parents are just instead
of throwing their kids at sweet 16 are
saying i got you 16 free meals i got you
16 free meals across seven boxes and
three free gifts that's your party tell
me who's doing that these days
tell me who that's cause i we
hello fresh is america's number one meal
kit always has been always will be
mm-hmm
what am i doing
pew
sounds like a laser
beam
beam we love beans did you know poor
sleep can cause weight gain mood issues
poor mental health and lower
productivity did you know that and that
sleeping a less than six to seven hours
a night is linked to reduced white blood
cell count not many people realize that
no they don't but having a consistent
nighttime routine is very important and
a better tomorrow starts tonight i'm not
joking the dream cocoa powder is
unbelievable you put me onto it yes the
beam dream can i tell you right now i
gave something to my dad yesterday i
swear to god
wow and then he got into having trouble
sleeping he's having trouble sleeping i
had to explain to him that this was
great
natural delicious helps me bubba i gave
him the powder he took it home and he's
going to try it this week because he's
he's having trouble sleeping it's so
good living dream
has given me some of my best sleeps and
i got a pitch for you beam
i got a pitch for you right here before
we give the promo code dream pass away i
got a pitch for you why not
why not hire
why not hire
houston rockets legend
hakeem elijah want to call him habi
malaja one
only good ideas here 98 of people
surveyed full sleep faster when taking
beam dreams and 99 of people experience
better sleep quality uh today our
listeners get a special discount on a
brand new delicious summer flavor of
dream powder sea salt caramel
find out why forbes the new york times
are all talking about bean and white
stressed by the world's top athletes and
business professionals yep okay scroll
for me pimpy if you want to try beam's
new
sea salt caramel dream powder guess what
it's only available for a limited time
so be sure to grab some performance out
at the end of this summer get up to 40
off 40 off when you go to
shopbeam.com hey babe and use code hey
babe at checkout
that shop b-e-a-m.com
hey babe and use code hey babe for up to
40 percent off that's a lot of
percentage points off almost half love
your beam habitat think about it
have you guys ever been on a city bike
on a city bike i have not i have if you
have yeah okay you like that i've been
on i did not like okay so now they have
electric city bikes and those are pretty
cool so electric meaning like it has a
motor you don't have to pedal it you
pedal but it's you pedal like it's like
nothing and it goes fast so but it's and
it's not it is not for exercise in the
slightest it is for
yeah yeah you know it's it's it's not
for exercises for getting the point at a
point i mean look you're still on there
cycling right it's not like yeah but
then there's the non there's the old
school ones and they're terrible right
like terrible meaning because they've
just been used so much right i think so
i mean i look they they go they're bikes
but first of all who's cleaning them
yeah
who's maintaining them yeah repair once
they say that they come by but no one's
cleaning them so who's touching those
things i mean uh
anyone could go over there and put their
[ __ ] ass on that thing you know like
i bet you people get on the seat i mean
like someone could take their ass and
shove the handlebar in it yeah then why
not why i wasn't all over it some
college kids i don't want to give con
you santacon you don't think they're
getting pissed and [ __ ] oh forget about
it that's santa
so i've only i've only taken a city bike
four times in my life the last time i
took it
my friend had an account and he did it
for both of us and we took an electric
and that was the only time i've ever had
a good experience so three times before
that every single time massive problems
with the bicycle massive the first time
i ever did it i like all right i guess
let's do this we found the place i took
the bike out first of all i had to like
open an account put the card in it was
all problems paying for the thing it
took like 10-15 minutes to get it all
worked out i get it i take the bike we
drive somewhere i go for a ride and then
we get to where we gotta go
i get there there's no freaking place to
put the bike back now i gotta go on the
app i gotta look it up i find a place i
go everyone's full i find i know place i
go everybody's full so i'm like i gotta
hand the bike back i need to go
so now i'm like fine what am i gonna do
so then we chained the bikes my friend
had to regulate we chained the bike up i
went into a store i didn't i couldn't
put it back so i and then i got back on
the thing again i had to find a thing
again i finally find one and the the
thing to put it in is broken and it
won't take it so i find another one i
finally get it back in the freaking
thing i go
it never registered it kept charging me
and then i took i took a basic ride and
it was like 37 or something like that
and then i had to like call them up and
be like i i got f and then the next two
times i tried it because everyone's like
it's great just you had a bad experience
the same exact thing happened three
times in a row three times in a row yeah
and i was cursing the whole time be like
this
thing yeah that's why for me if a city
has those lime scooters i'd prefer those
for that exact reason you don't you can
just leave them anywhere oh i [ __ ]
lime i [ __ ] with lime yeah and i got
the app like when i go to denver i'm on
them limes yeah i want in lines then
birds and lions
yeah and then you go to
l.a it's not just a scooter they got the
mini electric bikes yeah dope i i went
to downtown la once with all those uh
with those scooters it was wild and when
we go to like austin and stuff i said i
don't even get uber anymore i just hop
on that thing um
we have we
i'd like to get like off the dome
because i'm just tired
if you're tired i have a suggestion i
really because my yeah my kid's not
sleeping
you're tired sleep regression you want
to do something to wake you up we got
the sauce
we got the hot sauce
the hot sauce the hot ones hot sauce
so as you know from last week i was on
hot ones i told you that they gave me
the the three last dab sauces that are
10 out of 10 scoville units on so this
is the screamers this is what they when
they do the interview these are the ones
at the very very very end
and i took them on the show i brought
them and i think we set it up we talked
about doing it
i will do it if you will do it i know
that like we were going to decide if we
were going to do it or not
i've experienced it it's not good i
really don't want to do it
but
how long does it last
it depends how much you take i suppose
but it it
it lasts it'll last like really hot like
really really hot
maybe like
20 minutes plus 20 minutes plus yeah
but we'll have we would have to take
like milk or ice cream or something like
that do you have ice cream oh i should
have brought my lanta with me we have
ice cream
i mean look you're gonna need it i don't
think there's any way we could do this
without ice cream oh or milk there's no
way i people do it on the show but i
think that's because they end on these
and then the interview's over and they
kind of just like
but like i don't know has anyone ever
done it and it never
it they didn't affect them at all
you see people get through
doing the whole thing without even
taking the tip of water it's crazy when
you did the show did they have to ask me
of any medical problems blood pressure
issues they might have yeah i think they
actually might have
maybe i know i had to do covert testing
but like but
but the show if you ever watch a show
there you go pimp if you ever watch the
show
um
people a lot of people do really well
but i'm telling you
like i don't know how they do it because
when i took maybe because he told me
sean evans told me like you're really
going from zero to 100 on this because
you usually build to it but out of the
gate on truth or dab you just do the
hottest one so i guess that could have
been a shock factor involved why it was
like so like killer but did you ever see
you ever watch any of them some of them
were good but one of the most infamous
ones was dj khaled was on and it was in
the beginning like
towards more the beginning dj khaled i
don't know if the show had the
reputation i had yet okay and
dj khaled definitely didn't do any
research
and he came on and everyone loves to get
interviewed by this camera but i told
you yeah and dj came on he like brushed
it all off so badly and he was like he
was kind of like
um
he was kind of like like play he was
kind of like talking not talking down
but like he didn't give the show there
like the kind of like the the the
respect it was to be on it and then he
just was like now i'm not eating anymore
no one's ever done that i don't think
his people told him like no this is a
thing he goes all the way through it's a
good promotional tool he asks great
questions and he he it starts off with
tabasco
and he hit the tabasco and he goes what
are you kidding me he goes
he ate tabasco sauce and that's it and
then he was like no i can't do this i
can't do this and it's it's one of the
most watched ones because he was such a
g he was it was so he was so lame
because i am not good with spice
well then this is not for you this is
the hottest spice you could possibly
have
you're not going to do it right
uh i'll taste one of them why not you
will do it but i feel like you're the
one steering the ship and if we all have
it we might crash
it'd be a fun ship watch it sink they
want to watch this thing all right what
do we need we need cops we need spoons i
got chips we can put on the chips
are we doing are we doing all three of
them we're just doing one
i can't do all three i don't think i can
i think they're i think they're all on
on the bottle it says the level of heat
these all say 10 out of 10 heat
the the last dab so it's like the one
that ends the interview um the last day
of apollo is the world's only hot sauce
made with the apollo pepper the new
hottest pepper from guinness world
record holding chili breeder smoking ed
curry the apollo pepper channels the
sun's energy to bring new levels of
flavor and heat to the world the sun's
energy
caution the hottest sauce on hot ones
cranks the spice levels even higher with
this special triple x rated version of
the last dab three distinct strains
pepper x chocolate pepper x and peach
pepper x combined to smoke out the
celebrity guests and fans alike
dude
you tell me which one you want to do i
don't know
will it wake me up
yeah i think i think oh you're gonna be
awake
you're not gonna be tired
you're gonna you're gonna you
you're not gonna be able to you're not
gonna be in this state that you are now
no way
you're gonna be sweating and i couldn't
i couldn't stand still i had to
literally shake my body because
the
heat has to manifest itself somehow i
couldn't physically take it now i told i
don't do well with spice either so if
you're like me
it's not going to be good so i will tell
you it's not going to be enjoyable but
it might be good for the people that
listen and watch
i mean they gave it to me i don't i
would never use this in in real life and
so do people use this in real life or
this is just a thing
to i asked sean that i told you i think
he just said like well they have so many
now and i think some of them are really
delicious i think this one is more just
like a
let me try let me see if i can do this
unless just someone that could eat spice
i've a friend from india that will drink
this like water
right so what's his name
but
um
uh yeah dude i mean look shout out to
hot ones shout out to first we feast
they gave us this stuff it's kind of
like a little plug if you guys don't
know
if you're living under a rock and you
don't know um hot ones or or or the last
dab go to the youtube channel first we
feast and it's the it's a it's the best
it's it's like people answering a great
interview questions while they're taking
the hottest sauce in the world it's just
like
i know the combo of it is so
entertaining
i feel like you are
if you're doubting it no maybe we
shouldn't do it
i'm down i just i just hate spice
so sorry so the thing about that is that
is just all this is it's just hot spice
so i mean are you gonna do it knowing
that you i'll do it if you do it but i i
don't know why i'm gonna do it because
you don't actually want to do it no it
wasn't fun and it hurt and it was bad
but here this this will help you feel
better
hot peppers contain an alkaline
oil-based molecule called capsaicin yeah
which capsule yeah which sneaky triggers
the temperature sensitive pain receptors
in your mouth even though the molecule
itself doesn't produce heat or cause any
real damage unless you really overdo it
can the alkaline an oil-based molecule
which sneakily triggers the temperature
sensitive receptors even though the
molecule itself doesn't produce heat
but so what are we saying are we saying
that there's not real heat it's in our
head yeah
no that's not true no it's not in your
head it's in the receptors of your
tongue
how to cool your all right
how long this
dissipates in 15 minutes
what though
the burn from cap's assistant
yeah but that's
any capsule capsule since then
this is the ghost pepper x ghost peppers
i let's just
if the food is really hot it may lead to
nausea or vomiting
it could stimulate the production of
gastric mucus and temperatures
blow my nose my eyes tearing sweating
profusely immediately immediately within
a minute
i don't
i don't want to do it
[Laughter]
i don't yeah let's why don't we do it
why don't we do it and play badly we
were going to play mad libs last week
what is this this is hilarious
[Laughter]
it's woody from toy story dancing
like twerk look at this
it's so it's so realistic when you could
get it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and look at minnie mouse come at the
edge
[Laughter]
oh man you know what it's funny like in
the crowd the crowd dancing along
watching and filming it seems to be 100
uh black so and i'm imagining that the
person dancing is black too because the
person has really really good moves yeah
everyone there is black so it'd be weird
to be like one white guy in this outfit
if he took that helmet open that was a
white
like a bald white guy but that's what's
so funny about it too it's so funny to
see woody have moves like that
as a white joy
because the moves are
it's hilarious dance poops
some of it's a little even at the end
it's like a little like
feminine
yeah
is
sturdy
this has to have millions of views right
yeah this went all over last night i was
crying it was funny every time every it
looks like it's in brooklyn somewhere
too probably yeah i think we should do
the hot sauce
[Laughter]
what time we at
we're at uh 35 minutes oh we got time
yeah we got time should we have some
sauce and then watch some videos
you want to watch some videos with the
sauce
i'll tell you the thing i think the
reason that it's so funny even with the
show is because it's so hard to
talk and answer questions when your
mouth is burning but he's asking you
questions like for real that's the point
of the show yeah so i'm like we could
just take it taste it and that's it or
we could make a game out of it like i
mean we could gamify or we could try to
do like how many dips did you do
i did all three
but you ate a full wing i did uh one of
these on each one was it baked on the
wing or your dipping it was baked on the
wings it was baked on the wing so it's a
whole wing
yeah so a whole wing end and he didn't
you ate three of them i ate three yeah i
i think i ate the full first wing and
then like the second two i took a bite
of two out of each one but i think
you're only he was like how much time in
between each wing um
minute two minutes like your mouth was
still burning hot when you took a bite
of yet the next wing oh yeah
all right let's just do it just [ __ ]
oh really just do it i'll do a chip
okay just do it just do it i got to wake
up i'm depressed maybe this will help
who knows i am depressed i'm so
violently impressed me too bro i swear
to you i swear to you i've been talking
about the last two days i literally i
can't sleep at night i swear to god i
was this is me this morning i swear to
god i'm lying i i was asleep alarm went
off i went like this
like that and then sunk back in i don't
want to get that and i have no i have no
idea why same it just immediately was
like [ __ ] it it's [ __ ] i don't care
dude it's so depressing i'm like i got i
start counting my blessings i'm like how
why can i feel this way this this this
this i'm so happy healthy family yeah
just that the other i'm like i should be
thrilled everything's good why can't i
just feel good why can't i just feel
happy i'm happy about everything i'm
thankful for everything why isn't the
feeling coming out of me right i'll wake
up in the middle of the night or not two
nights ago couldn't fall asleep through
the night because depression
couldn't fall asleep
literally did not sleep i slept for like
from like 7 a.m to 9 00 a.m i stayed up
through the night i was laying there at
one point
just thinking of the worst thoughts
and then i just was like felt tears
coming down my face yeah then i'm just
like i'm just wiping the tears i'm like
trying to go to sleep and it's just not
happening maybe this will help then yeah
let's just think honestly
it's one of those things where i bet you
i'm so depressed right now i'm not even
gonna feel the spice
i think you're wrong on that let's pour
it in our pee hole yeah
all right how do we do it what are we
here what do we do so all right
all right the last step so we'll just
pour it in a cup
okay hold on
still smells like salad dressing
okay dip it right on the chip i guess
let's just use the one you open then i
don't want to open up all three
i think
doing all three is not any different
than doing three bites of one
right
different profiles
you should taste them
let's do one let's do one he gonna do
one
okay all right so you don't want to do
you don't want to do all three let's
open the first one see what happens
let's see let's see what it does to my
depression all right let's do it all
right pour it in oh we're gonna pour it
in the cup we're gonna pour right in the
chip
guys
it's no secret that women love beards
and we love growing them or at least
trying to but having a great looking
beard requires work
whether it's beard growth oils or
styling products top-of-the-line trimmer
there's a small army of products
required to grow your beard the best way
it can luckily beer club is here to help
as the leader in beard first men's
growth and grooming beard club delivers
quality hardware and consumables that'll
help you get a better thicker and fuller
looking beard i got some products in the
mail i don't know if you've got yours
yet again yeah use the trimmer today
whoa comes a little stand pops right off
as soon as i was actually not even
considering shaving but i plugged it
right in by the sink after i brushed my
teeth i looked i said let me straighten
that out straighten that out plug that
[ __ ] in and i put the cedar balm on and
i love because i love smelling like a
fart you love a balmy beard i love a
forest i love christmas i love cedar
furs a balsam
we can get into trees another time okay
uh to get started go to
beardclub.com and use the code hey babe
to take the beard quiz they'll recommend
a growth or grooming kit that's tailored
to your beard's needs the highlight of
the grooming kit is the pt45 trimmer i
use it today it's truly a beard changing
device there's no painful uh hair
pulling it's sturdy and it's it has
great battery life the same trimmer that
nba player james the beard hardened uses
what wow that's crazy he's also an
investor in the company i love james
harden he's cool he really is cool he's
pretty damn cool
the growth kit features sprays to
strengthen and moisturize your beard
hair your oils at prime follicles for
optimal growth and derma roller that
rejuvenates dormant hair follicles no
matter what type of bait you have beard
club has the perfect fit for your needs
beer club over two million beards sir
grow your best beard today and take 20
off your first order when you go to
beardclub.com
hey babe and use the code hey babe
that's
beardclub.com code hey babe for 20 off
your first
order you're the best
dude all those times that you were
walking through the sand
yeah and you
saw that we were walking to the sand
right you saw only one set of footprints
what do you think was happening
you were behind me
you were um i was behind you and i was
walking your exact prince to throw
people off to throw people off yeah
exactly
do you know why free trials renew
without your consent it's a business
scam out to get you don't let greedy
corporations pocket your money download
rocket money
to take control of your subscriptions i
love that that was really good rocket
money
burning up all your subscriptions wow
you have to check out rocket money
they help you manage and cancel
subscriptions you don't need you don't
want or you simply forgot about what
wait a second
dude
rocket money
wow yeah because they changed their name
yes
a new company called rocket money i like
it because it i was like that's true
bill
and that was one of my favorite apps
true bill really yes why well for one
true bill has grown from a bill
management app into a full-on
personal
finance empowerment tool that helps over
3.4 million people wow with budgeting
and more
saving each of their members on an
average 700
a year 700 hours 700 dollars a year yeah
rocket money
bottom line rocket money is everything i
loved about you bill
but with the fresh look and feel
[Music]
rocketmoney.com
stock cancel your unused descriptions
and save money at rockfucking.com
hey babe or download the app from the
apple store
or the google play store
rocket money
burning
rocket money burning up your
subscriptions
rocket money singing the song burns up
time in the ad yeah
rocket money
tbh i like the rocket monkey
that's a joke and i totally disagree
totally disagree true bill aka rocket
money has saved me money
rocket money save yourself 700 a year
[Laughter]
oh yeah there's a full hair in that cup
one of pimp's [ __ ] beard hairs
now do we have spoons for the ice cream
just in case
it actually doesn't look too bad
i would be worried about if i was eating
chicken wings is because i have a
tendency to pick my nose and rub my eyes
if you accidentally rub your eyes oh do
not
touch your face and do not go to the
bathroom
don't be you
for how long uh until until you wash
your hands
you will you'll get this in your eyes
and they may not know if you want hot
ones yeah anything nose yeah yeah
and don't touch your genitals
for until you wash off yeah
well you know what you're not holding a
wing we're gonna dip the chip into this
so you might be okay but if you rub your
mouth or whatever just because
you got spoons yeah let's open these
just in case just in case these are
right here
oh i thought that you liked that one
yeah
read what that says
because i i just read it and i'm like oh
shout out jenny's by the way shout out
jenny jenny's sent me these and i love
jenny's and especially if you guys get
that cream chee everything bagel cream
cheese one again please send it to me
it's the best ice cream i've ever had
savannah buttermint a buttery after
dinner mint ice cream with white
chocolate flecks yeah but look what it's
supposed to be based on on the side
there
i just realized the banana butter mint
is inspired by those melt in your mouth
pillow mint candies in the restaurant of
our grand parents generation do you know
the diamonds yeah this is the size it's
not my grandparents generation we had it
and it's still now remember
you know they probably don't have those
now with diners right yeah the bowl of
mints with a spoon at the counter yeah
in this day and age
in a in a pandemic world the greeks
never stop yeah man
you know what pim can we get bowls so
we're not shoveling out of the is it
good
delicious right jenny's don't miss
jenny's is there like a jenny's
store somewhere yeah it's they
originated in ohio and now they're in
many many states but they do delivery so
i just get them shipped to the house
chinese.com yeah
that's amazing ice cream it's they don't
miss
and it's listen this is not you know
this is not healthy alternative ice
cream this is just go [ __ ] yourself
yeah so what flavor did you go with
savannah savannah buttermint
no no of the hot sauce
oh we went with the first one we're
trying at least is the the last dab
apollo sauce made with the apollo pepper
apollo pepper sauce let's do it creed
apollo creed um apollo 13 on the new
[ __ ] i'm the new tom hanks
it's going to end the same way yeah
apollo beats dead by the way
he died going up against something he
couldn't handle
all right all right all right let's do
it let's do it let's do it you stop
being a [ __ ] chris this is why you're
depressed because you don't face your
fears you don't just walk through the
door even though your life and the
things of your circumstances you don't
like you are too scared to walk through
that door which could potentially be
freedom could potentially be no
depression could potentially be
happiness but you stay in your
circumstances you just sit there so now
you must walk through and eat that chip
wow all right
sal
try it
i agree all right ready okay
all right but let's get the same amount
on okay okay let's get a good coating
like how about like something like that
something like that
get in there like get in there like that
okay okay
all right all right all right all right
all right
um i this might not be that bad because
maybe it's not big on the full win
or it could be worse
i don't know what we're going to feel
after just this we might want to do it
more or might not want to do it more
okay are you biting from the hot side
first
okay
ready yeah on three
okay one two three
it's hit me immediately
it's immediately hard
does happen the last time i got hiccups
i got the hiccups immediately
i'm waiting for
is there any milk left
is there enough milk
i can't do this again
i already can't do this again i swear to
god
i swear to god i can't do this again
wait it's gonna get
did it even hit yet it's bad i got the
hiccups already
i don't know why i get the hiccups so
immediately
does it get worse from here
[Music]
i want to do another one and play mad
libs
i can't do that again
so i'm not lying to man it hurts so bad
and i feel like i can't breathe
imagine this is how you die
the ice cream helps the ice cream house
only for the minute that's second
that's in your mouth well you have to
keep eating ice cream then
oh
no joke try not to eat the ice cream see
what happens to you
yeah
we never heard anything about your
disney trip either
my disney trip is it bad is it heavy
oh they're acting they're playing it up
i i can't explain to you how much
pain i'm in right now and i would trade
anything in the world to get rid of this
pain and go back to just being depressed
because it comes in it comes in stages
like my depression
thank you jenny
you're a cold hearted [ __ ]
i genuinely
i can't that was from just dipping a
chip in it and you ate that entire one
eat three wings full
all right pimp's gonna go in ah
um you wanna try another
i'm gonna try not flavor i can't i can't
honestly i know you guys did it and i
know
and i don't care you guys can call me
[ __ ] i can't i can't do it any it i'm
in so much like
like i mean i would say severe pain
how much does it take
i took a decent amount i already feel it
no you can't drink the milk i'm not
milk's for headliners only
oh yeah you feel it right down your
throat
i love that they made it a way to
torture celebrities
it's hard to talk
i can't man i'll interview you imagine
doing three wings of that i can't that's
the thing i can't i don't care everybody
can ask me and call me i mean just get
in line
everyone can roast me and say that i'm a
failure i would just say well i guess
i'll see you at dinner on sunday because
that's what everyone says anyway and i i
this is not i will tell you this this is
not helping with my depression it's
making me feel worse
and kind of realizing that members of my
family are right
dude i'm actually getting a headache
um i'll tell you something
hiccups and a headache um
some people don't
drink anything or do anything they just
let it sit i don't know how you do that
it's like it's like it's like my mouth
is so hot that i'm freezing
six-year-old alexa
changes name due to amazon related
bullying yeah i agree wait what happened
the lady changed your name
because because every time she gets
called for dinner
the the
fridge turns on
sal listen
i have the utmost respect for what you
do
i i can't dude i can't either i'm just
i'm just doing it because
we have the ice cream but
i'm trying to make good content
i found a great clip last night from the
80s 93 if you guys can watch it
so corny what does my therapist always
say
don't resist accept
it's like you always say to the
listeners surrender surrender
[Laughter]
one more with this one and then lean
back
and as long
as we possibly
can
through the pain
don't take ice cream or milk or water
see if you guys can go i mean it might
take 30 seconds it might take two
minutes it might take 10 seconds
i couldn't do it i had to go to my land
to eight seconds in but like
even if we sit here and punch the couch
and scream and stuff let's see how long
we could do it if we could make it like
a minute
wanna see if we can make it a minute
let's see if we can make it a minute
i have a pounding headache
and my tongue is burning right now
can you get the hair out of the cup
where's the cup
oh yeah yeah yeah if you just get that
hair out of the cup
i think it's on the bottom
okay okay put it in
oh my god i swear to god dude i
my heart is racing so what's the next
flavor what's what's on the label what
do i say about it
this is uh the last dab carolina reaper
special edition
reaper edition
the last dab single pepper series
remixes this spiciest sauce on hot ones
replacing
pepper x with some of the other heavy
weights of the chili world experience
smoking ed curry's world famous carolina
reaper and then
in its blazing glory
tamed only by the zingy blend of mustard
ginger and turmeric chris is so worried
it's the most worried i've ever seen
chris
go like this let's just do this
take a chip
ready yep was i supposed to shake this
what
do you think anyone's ever accidentally
gotten this in their eye yes i know i
gotta be
well it's gotta be a lot of averages
okay okay
go ahead all right hold it steady
i'm gonna put what i gave me okay okay
okay okay okay
pam oh
pimp you doing this with us
i'm not gonna be able to i'm not gonna
let me put it on the chip for you
because i don't think i'm gonna be able
to
yeah put like that though
like that though yeah see like that
though
i don't feel good at all man i do feel
nauseous
yeah do you feel nauseous too yeah yeah
that's a good amount i do i feel
something off with my head yeah let's
don't throw up let's do it all right
ready all right let's go
all right
um this one
this one is not hitting me like the
other one it might kick in a little
later i'm feeling it
this one is not hitting my mine's
speeding up now it's getting there oh
really it's a slow burn yeah mine's
speeding the [ __ ] up right now
oh my god i just choked it it burned
oh man what do you guys think about this
article ooh
122 year old woman said she smoked for
100 years and eat two pounds of
chocolate weekly i think that i'm this
122 year old woman
yeah i have
so much
saliva yeah this is the saliva is crazy
this is a slower burn
the other one burned immediately it's
like your head vibrates huh
oh god
i really can hate you
oh my gosh i can't i'm out oh man
a minute in 10 seconds
this one
is a slow burn
the other one's fast i can't i [ __ ] i
haven't i've been crumbled yet let's go
let's go
you spilled ice cream all over your
jogger i gotta go
your lulu's got ice cream on him it's
all right baby they're [ __ ]
lululemons
oh man this hurts
the ice cream was too
i don't know
this one is like there's no [ __ ]
escaping it you know what i mean
[Music]
yep this one is no escaping
i still haven't cracked yet
need milk
what do you guys think of this article
mom caught drunk driving while dropping
off
kids at school
you know
it's like that david tell joke when he
goes uh what's that david tell joke when
he's like uh
drunk driving i don't know i forgot
one of the first jokes i ever remember
tell doing
when i saw him at the cellar
in 1994 was
i think your movie was i don't know what
to do
i'll just say the movie was titanic
the people listening on audio must be
like what the [ __ ] is this show i
watched he sounds like a sex tape
he said
i'd love to just listen to the audio of
this
michael jackson
oh man
oh my i still have been cracking it
myself and cracked my tongue is like
numb
it just doesn't even you don't feel a
burn
i feel the pain of it but it just
it just feels like there's just
something taking up room in my mouth
it's weird yeah
i genuinely rather have a [ __ ] in my
mouth
we can arrange that right now
[Laughter]
oh man jenny's is getting devoured
there's 800 calories in one part
it still hurts
that's right i'll go for a jog later
um what do you think was worse
that one was so much [ __ ] worse so
much worse is what's going on because
there is no you can't run away from it
run away
run away
oh my god pimp you want some ice cream
buddy no i'm chilling man i haven't
cracked yet i'm doing good i'm hanging
in pimp has not taken a sip of any how
is pimp not taking a sip of [ __ ]
anything yet no i haven't taken a sip of
anything yet
i want to see how long i go yep
i don't do genetic composition is
different i have genetic cesspool i've
emerged from i have no benefit here ah
yeah he said i went to go see titanic
i didn't want to but the girl i was
stalking did
david tell me yeah you guys want to see
an awful commercial from 93. uh one time
david tell i was in the comments selling
i don't know where he just goes dolphins
the puerto ricans of the sea
no explanation no contracts and people
like what the [ __ ] does that mean
simply attach the special double back
fastener to any phone then attach the
phone relief
it's perfect for remotes now talk
hands-free anywhere else yeah office
work is a pain for mr faulkner
this guy's in an office with a phone
velcro to the [ __ ] side of his head
[Laughter]
the newest cordless phone ever like a
first cordless phone it's a phone this
actually makes you feel better if you go
like this
it's called phone relief and it's
basically you velcro the phone to your
face
[Music]
my heart's beating fast yeah
my numbers are bad
does your family say blood pressure
what's your pressure
blood pressure my family says pressure
oh my god
oh we should have watched that and it
was from 1993 we should have watched our
93rd episode celebration oh that was the
last week see this this truck got into
an accident in memphis and spilled
that's all alfredo sauce
lost in the sauce tractor trailer in
memphis carrying alfredo sauce spilled
on the highway oh my god it's all
alfredo sauce it's it's like a quarter
mile long
mateo lane was seen sliding through it
look at this winnie the pooh is coming
out with a horror movie we got to watch
the trailer people are up in arms about
winnie the pooh being murdering people
well jagged edge productions yeah i used
to listen to their music
see first of all
i know your social players couldn't
handle this
but i'll be really saying what's up my
heart
let's make
[Music]
we put in this relationship
who knew
[Music]
[Music]
we ain't getting no young girl we might
as well do
let's get married baby let's get married
is this how hot ones went
ah
this is when hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey